c'était principalement pour pour la
france
mais ouais je me suis je me suis décidé
à le faire la semaine dernière quand
vous avez pris cette édition me
souvenais pas dit ouais ça a été un truc
de fou comment je vais faire quand vous
êtes passé les gens se posent la
question si vous êtes élu et prenne
place des vrais prix des places en fait
j'avais pris une place pour la demi
finale de nadal d'accord parce qu'à la
base je pensais le faire sur sur cette
demi finale là d'accord et puis du coup
l'un des joueurs s'est frayé la cheville
donc exactement avec centre dans ce bref
donc vous ai dit moi je vais le faire
sur l'autre voilà c'est ça va jouer je
suis resté du coup dans l'enceinte du
stade je me suis cachée du coup dans les
loges parce que j'avais faim j'avais des
places très très haut et russie en fait
à descendre au moment du chaos justement
autour de se demander qu'est ce qui
allait se passer le match aller est
arrêté je suis descendu sur les loges et
du coup je me suis caché dans les loges
de tf1
[Rires]
c'est l'été
cinéma
décalé c'est vraiment pas leur jour à
votre avis et vos amis alors et donc
aidé on pouvait donc là vous cacher
ouais je du coup je me cachais c'est de
parce qu'en fait il est risqué de tout
le monde et du coup moi j'avais sacha au
téléphone quand c'est un genre que
j'étais une visible ou man comme ça
personne n'a encore quelques métro et du
coup voilà j'ai réussi à rester sur
l'eau deux demi-finales toi sur le final
et après j'ai j'ai attendu un peu et
j'ai réussi après aller encore plus
proche du terrain du coup là dans le
clan ou chanel et après j'ai du coup
j'étais juste à côté de du terrain et et
après j'ai fait ce qui passe qui a été
vu par voilà voudrait nous dire pourquoi
vous arrêtez ça que vous allez mettre un
petit peu le summum c'est important
ça les porter ce t-shirt avec écrit il
reste 1028 jours vous allez nous dire
pourquoi il reste 20 minutes 28 jours
dans un instant et voir ces signes ici
est incroyable roland garros parce que
vous êtes dit c'est l'événement du
moment ouais c'était au stade de france
chez les anglais
n'ont surtout que ces week-ends du coup
tous les tous les regards étaient
tournés vers roland-garros et et que la
dernière innovation on a envie de
détourner le regard pour qu'en fait ce
soit placé sur l'urgence climatique dans
laquelle on est alors on va en parler
dans un sens de l'urgence climatique
parce que vous avez fait comme 40 heures
de garde à vue qu'est ce qui s'est passé
après votre geste après monde j'ai été
amené au poste de sécurité ou là du coup
les bas légaliste pas très très content
de la normale oui bien sûr je le
comprends et pauvre en plus eux ils ont
dû se fracasser les ce que ça aurait pu
être beaucoup plus grave et c'est vrai
que voilà c'est la cité pour un message
nous parler dans un instant mais c'est
vrai que là
et je pense qu'ils ont eu peur aussi au
début parce que en fait je pensais que
j'avais un détonateur dans la main sur
ben msik mais du coup ça pour ça que
j'ai levé la main en fait j'avais juste
de la colle juste on va enfin non
violente et c'était pas voilà j'étais
pas j'allais pas me péter ou quoi que ce
soit quand même et comprirent qu'ils ne
savent pas vraiment ils disent s'ils
respectent ça peut être est extrêmement
rare vous avez eu peur un moment au
moment d'y aller ou pas du tout vous est
dérivé je suis je non j'ai pas eu peur
se le dise moi j'ai peur là maintenant
ce qui est de vous avez vous venez de
parler 1028 jours aux avait été placé en
garde à vue qui s'est passé est ce qu'on
vous a dit bah du coup on m'a dit qu'ils
avaient placées en garde à vue et donc
ça je savais en fait en faisant cette
action en entrant résistance civile je
sais que je suis amené à faire de la
garde à vue et du coup une garde à vue
normalement ces 24 heures qui peut être
amenée à 48 heures donc moi je m'étais
préparé pour 24 heures
et en fait j'ai été déférés et du coup
ça a duré en fait mais je ne sais pas
pourquoi aussi je pense que c'est pour
l'exemple c'est un bug ans est
importante parce que là c'est inique
vous dire à chaque fois à manifestation
il va y avoir une personne qui va qui va
venir envoyer au stade de france ils ont
pas pris 40 40 heures
c'est normal c'était des anglais c'est
au fait merci géraldine maillet on se
passera de vos commentaires
merci géraldine maillet un pra la
paroisse qu'on a
justement parlé dans un instant alizés
de de votre votre combat et avec sacha
également qu est ce que vous avez pensé
son geste après on va nous dire pourquoi
mais est ce que vous êtes et géraldine
toi en tant que grande patience et moi
je trouve que votre geste forcément il
ya une jurisprudence vous savez il ya
parent monica seles qui avait été
poignardé par quelqu'un est entré sur le
court donc forcément le tennis est un
peu traumatisé par ce genre de happening
après oui on voit que vous êtes
pacifique vous êtes calme vous n'êtes
pas une sorte de décérébrés hystérique
sur le court vous voulez faire passer un
message donc effectivement voilà
malheureusement votre message bon très
bien il est passé mais après ils ont
voulu absolument vous sanctionner pour
voilà pour pas que ça donne des idées à
d'autres mais voilà après effectivement
je trouve qu'il ya une sorte de
aujourd'hui de de violence qui dans
votre cas pas une violence mais il ya
une sorte de valve la sécurité est
débordé par tous en fait même à roland
garros ils sont complètement dépassés
les gants s'allier sont complètement
dépassés c'est incroyable après le court
est réussie parce que pour le dépasser
mais non mais la gérer la très bien
gérer parce que voilà là aussi on a
essayé fort knox oui un geste
inadmissible au nom de votre idéal bobos
dont vous allez nous parler
mais vous avez créé une jurisprudence il
ya des gens qui vont entrer maintenant
parce que c'est possible vous allez
donner des idées à des gens qui vont
entrer pour frapper pour être violent ça
je ne vous parle même pas alors je vous
réponde à ça alizée
mercialys
répondait ça a répondu leur permettent
juste de répondre que en fait la tête
que vous pardonnez pas cet acte mais
nous on pardonne pas non plus que tout
notre futur en fait et condamné parce
qu'aujourd'hui si on fait rien pour
alerter sur l'urgence climatique c'est
ça qui va se passer donc désolé d'avoir
perturbé un court de tennis désolé
d'avoir créé jurisprudence met
aujourd'hui en fait si on fait rien
c'est mon futur qui est condamné c'est
celui de l'alizé et c'est celui
potentiellement des offres de tous vos
enfants si vous êtes solide daniel
facturé à rien futur
regardez ainsi on ne l'avait pas vu
cette image c'était un vendredi à roland
garros très vous avez des images jusqu'à
mach pression chez marin cilic juste
l'image ainsi une image quoi
on
se passera petit commentaire
[Rires]
voilà donc voilà bon voilà donc on a vu
après alizé c'est bon merci
c'est bon merci
à 10 et donc vous allez me dire pourquoi
vous aviez ce t-shirt avec il reste 1028
jours mais juste avant il ya sacha qui
voulaient répondra à gilles verdez 1 aux
siens sur ce qui vous a dit parce qu'il
a été un peu un petit peu dur avec vous
pouvez dire ce que vous avez dit j'ai
dit que je trouvais que c'était un acte
de militantisme stupide au nom d'un
idéal bobos et que vous pouviez donner
des idées
dévastatrice à des gens qui eux
pourraient être armés et représenter un
danger pour des sportifs ou autres
pour que vous avez dit condamner en
faite le et c est qu on avait créé
jurisprudence et moi je vous ai répondu
en fait que la race si on n'agit pas on
qu'on est en train de condamner notre
futur a su égaliser combien et a
sûrement vos enfants à tous en fait est
que c'est tout ce qui nous reste à faire
pour nous sauver et justement analysé
pour raconter les 1020 de ce jour mais
aujourd'hui c'est ça en fait on est
condamné à avoir des actes comme vous
dites stupide peut-être pour en fait
réussir à attirer l'attention sur la bo
enfin ça va devenir abdominale donc en
fête et ont préféré ne pas avoir à faire
des actes stupides comme vous dites les
gens continuent à faire c'est un on est
positionné mais qui a trouvé ce geste
déplacé ou déprimés et daniel moysan le
combat est noble la façon de le faire
arriver pas noble ont en plus on parle
de ça tout le temps à s'cusez moi vous
pouvez pas dire que c'est un sujet qu'on
mais sûrement la pire on ne parle que de
ça en ce moment non pas encore qu'est ce
qu'on fait
je suis je pense que c'est
malheureusement un combat perdu d'avancé
parce que tout le monde est d'accord
problème c'est ça c'est que c'est une
course sur laquelle tout le monde est
d'accord mais on ne fait rien parce que
on veut notre petit confort personnel et
ça c'est pas en allant preuves à faire
une action comme ça et moi je suis assez
d'accord gilles est toujours dans
l'extrême mais en tout cas avec ce qu'il
a dit c'est pas en faisant ça que ça va
faire changer la mentalité des gens je
suis désolé les gouverne tout le monde
est conscient de ce qu'il faudrait faire
mais on ne fait pas parce qu'on n'a pas
envie les gens continuent à prendre
l'avion et il continue à dire que c'est
pas bien mais ils continuent tous allés
partout donc c'est perdu d'avancé suis
désolé mais c'est pas en faisant ce
genre de choses mais
à l'elysée
que sa mère souffre poser une question
est ce que vous avez un meilleur plan
dans les deux à trois ans qui reste
alors sincèrement qu'elle a pas de plan
[Applaudissements]
ça puisse changer les choses mais
malheureusement en parler on en parle
tout le temps de parcours de centre est
avec dan et d'innovation c'est une
demande et une revendication qu'à la
rénovation énergétique des bâtiments
donc en fait les actions comme ça c'est
aussi pouvoir mettre en avant notre
message on a une demande donc en fait on
sait par où commencer les scientifiques
nous disent certes il ne reste pas
beaucoup de temps mais on peut le faire
on va le faire alors on va on va en
prendre un sens des mines 28 jours qui
n'a pas aimé oui j'ai eu raymond
monsieur g mois le combat oui j'ai pas
aimé qu'ils allaient viennent en
intervention comme ça parce que comme on
l'a dit c'est dangereux parce que ça
donne des idées à des tarés après votre
truc qui n'est pas tard et il est pour
sauver la planète sauver nos enfants
parce que quand c'est les plus anciens
qui parle c'est pas pareil ils ont fait
leur vie nos enfants vous voulez les
jeunes vous êtes en difficulté avec la
planète vous avez conscience de ça que
nous on n'avait pas conscience de sans
rouler à fond avec les voitures on s'en
foutait mais comme on a dit non mais ça
on pollue et on s'en foutait sans
déconner que c'est vraiment
tout seul gt gt 280 sur l'autoroute
charest à la bombe et les calmes tout
pollué maintenant on fait on progresse
on progresse moi ce que ce qui
m'interpelle de là où je vais plus loin
c'est que autres ont dit que la france
qui représente 1% de la de la pollution
mondiale il ya toujours des paquebots
qui circulent ya toujours des avions il
y aura d autres trucs mais comment on
fait si le monde n'est pas avec nous
comme en fait si le monde ne suit pas
tantôt ton action elle est géniale je
peux le faire tous les jours non lui dit
de rouler en électrique oui on va rouler
en électrique oui on va moins consommer
mais même si on roule ou en calèche
demain on y aura toujours là bien sûr et
ce qu'elle fait elle pollue peu comme
ailleurs j'essaye de comprendre je veux
bien qu'il fasse c'est bien à nos
enfants mais est ce que c'est le monde
alors le pays entier les pays entier se
mettre d'accord juste
pour nous expliquer malaisie ce chantier
moi moi j'ai en tête c'est aussi faim
certes il faut que l'effort soit fait à
l'échelle de la planète mais en sus la
france commence pas par où on va
commencer et c'est sûrement la france
aussi c'est surtout nous en tant
qu'individu c'est pour ça que moi que
j'ai choisi j'ai agi en fait c'est vous
tous c'est hyper important que vous vous
disiez en fait c'est pas faut pas
attendre que les gens agissent c'est
nous anton 4e en individuel et chacun
individuellement je sais qu'on dit que
chacun individuellement on peut pas
faire quelque chose aujourd'hui j'ai
fait quelque chose on en a parlé c'est
je sais juste se dire ça pour pas
attendre que la france et que le monde
attendre que vous en faites vous fassiez
quelque chose et à part la pink est ce
que vous faites concrètement vous dans
votre coin dans mon quotidien c'est pour
ça que chez dernière innocent c'est oui
je suis engagé à fond dans dernières
innovations parce que pour moi en fait
c'est ça c'est le meilleur plan que j'ai
trouvée pour sauver ma vie et pour
sauver mes proches non mais le plus
important c'est quoi 1028 jours alors il
nous reste 1028 jour ces courtes ça
c'est sacré qui veut dire sacha ou
sacha voulait répondre ah bah non c'est
bon d'en mesurer ce que c'était assez
clair que faut bien commencer quelque
part aujourd'hui on est des citoyens et
citoyennes françaises donc bon on va
arrêter de se jeter à l'eau ça fait 30
ans que ça pourquoi 1028 jours
maintenant 1025 à longny 28 jours du
maintenant 1025 c'est en fait on a
compté à partir du moment où on a fini
enfin l'ultimatum a été fini avec le
gouvernement on a envoyé un ultimatum
il ya des bus début mars on lui a laissé
un mois pour mettre en place en fait
notre demande de rénovation énergétique
des bâtiments qui n'a pas été mis en
place et donc du coup on est rentré en
résistance civile après à la fin de cet
ultimatum et donc du passé quad en 1025
jour en 2025 jours c'est pas il n'ya pas
le valais va pas y avoir la fin du monde
alors arrivé directement
que j'ai des points ça c'est juste
derrière voudrait dire qu'il nous reste
une très petite fenêtre d'action une
très petite et en fait c'est dans les
deux à trois ans qu'on peut encore faire
quelques tours histoire c'est ça c'est
ça sera trop tard et les 28 jours c'est
que parmi les 28 jours ok ce sera pas la
fin d'un monde mais ce sera trop bien ça
trop tard voilà c'est ça c'est juste que
vous avez compris le monde dans lequel
tulle avec elle quelques calculs comme
enfin comment vous le concrétiser cette
histoire de jours vous avez fait des
déçus que l'étude
c'est les deux à trois ans qui nous
restent avant qu'on dépasse donc si tu
es le meilleur d'accord ça calcule les
points de bascule quand le point après
si vous voulez vraiment qu'on parle
climat et qu'on parle des points de
bascule on pourra revenir avec un expert
du geiq ce constat que ça soit
exactement pour savourer ce soir mais en
gros c'est scientifiquement prouvé on a
déjà dépassé les 25 degrés on veut juste
essayer de ne pas dépasser les 2 degrés
si on attendait ce degré juste ces 100
millions de morts sur les routes c'est
un milliard de personnes qui vont devoir
bouger et vont aller où oui ça va être
catastrophique a bien conscience que
c'est ça la solution chez moi c'est je
pose c'est trop petit
si on fait rien les plans qu'on peut
avoir même heure avant de raisons mais
oui ce nom mais tant parler signal de
genre il est plein en fait pour le futur
mais le problème c'est que si on n'agit
pas dans les deux à trois ans le reste
tous les plans futurs ça sera pas
possible ce qui va être possible et ce
qui va être le cas ces gens dégâts des
familles c'est le chaos c'est la
destruction de la travers mes repères
chacun
invitation ouverte on va sur les routes
le monde u17 a envie de venir viens voir
ce qui se passait dans les routiers
petit du coup on va polluer
l'avion qu'une fois par an non mais non
mais ça va porter des messages et y ait
une demande interne et rénovation on a
une demande c'est la rénovation
énergétique des bâtiments on s'adresse
au gouvernement c'est quoi ça notre la
rénovation énergétique des bâtiments ça
consistant qui paye ça et on fait et qui
paye la rénovation énergétique des
bâtiments c'est la rénovation globale et
performante donc c'est à dire voyez une
maison il ya un toit il ya des fenêtres
et une chaudière pour être performant et
du coup ne pas avoir trop chaud ni trop
froid et ne pas trop consommer du coup
pour essayer d'avoir un habitabilité
normal dans un appartement en gros faut
isoler sa maison mais le problème
aujourd'hui c'est qu'on pensait que les
vignerons de quoi payer la désolation de
leur maison là ils ont pas de quoi faire
le gouvernement s'engage à déjà mais le
gouvernement c'est avec les impôts des
français les gens ils sont pas prêts
pour payer en a qui peuvent pas payer un
choix payer 2 c'est un choix certes
rédigé par dix c'est d'accord mais
rejoindre les impôts a jailli dans quoi
mais regarde moi je te tutoie moi j'ai
changé les fenêtres j'ai fait 10 hall
annonçant que faire
mais c'est celui que j'ai mis le truc
j'ai tout mis à 19 degrés il ya des gens
qui seront pas aidés par l'état et qui
changeront pas leur
demander s'ils ont un contrat tu as ta
vidéo
la désinflation un leader si la mise et
sasha mercialys des chercheurs est
revenue parmi nous donner leurs messages
voilà mille 28 jours norris 1028 joue
beaucoup du coup maintenant exactement